♪♪
-Happy Thanksgiving!
So, I sang the line,
"It's 5:00 on a Saturday,"
and was told the line
from Billy Joel's "Piano Man"
is, "It's 9:00 on a Saturday.
That is true, but...
I was not singing "Piano Man,"
by Billy Joel.
I was singing "Keyboard Guy,"
by Bobby Jake.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
All right.
So we had a monologue.
There was a story
in the news about a python
eating an alligator
that happened in, um...
where did it happen?
It happened...
Python eating an alligator.
It happened
in one of the 50 states.
[ Laughter ]
South-- it was
a Southern state, right?
[ Laughter ]
Oh! It was Florida.
[ Clears throat ]
The punch line was
a python eating an alligator,
or what's also known
as a Florida turducken.
Now...people were upset
because a turducken
is three elements --
turkey, duck, chicken --
whereas a python
eating an alligator is only two.
We forgot to mention that when
they cut the alligator open,
he had a little bit
of meth in him.
[ Laughter ]
So you can call it a Florida
turducken or a pyallimeth.
[ Laughter ]
Which is important to know,
because if you're ever in
Florida, do not
refer to yourself
as a polymath
because it sounds too close
to pyallimeth.
You can get in trouble if you're
down in Florida and you're
being all braggy about yourself.
"Oh, I consider myself
a bit of a Renaissance man.
You could say a polymath," and
someone's like, "Hey, Cletus."
[ Laughter ]
"This feller fancies
he can eat a whole alligator."
And then...
In general, if you're
a polymath, don't say it.
Let other people say it.
Ooh, Monday, we had a joke...
about a turkey with a knife.
And someone said --
We were informed
the turkey would
hold a knife in its foot,
its claw, not its wing.
But it couldn't --
it couldn't hold the knife
in its claw 'cause that's where
it holds its gun!
[ Laughter ]
It's a tur-knife-gun.
This is fascinating to me.
It's pronounced "gay-la"
if it's a noun, meaning a party.
It's pronounced "ga-luh"
if it's an adjective
describing a party --
a gala affair.
And if it's a party with
legal gambling and prostitution,
it's pronounced Nevada.
[ Laughter ]
I was told I held
the Maryland state flag
upside down.
This is how I held it last week.
As you can see,
that is an eyesore.
But this,
oh, yi yi, beauty, beauty.
[ Laughter ]
Also, this is
the only state flag
that's also
a Magic Eye poster.
[ Laughter ]
If you stare at it long enough,
you see...
like, Maryland celebrities.
[ Laughter ]
Stringer Bell.
Audience is still split
on tank-top week.
Some people thought
that when I wore my tank top,
I looked scrawny.
One person said
my arms look so good,
it made them self-conscious.
Again, we can decide.
Let's take a look.
I don't --
[ Laughter ]
No, I think it's fi--
I think it's like average arms.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's average arms
for a late-night talk-show host.
So, uh...
We joked -- we talked about
a guy wearing a stovepipe hat
and how you could fit
an entire week's worth
of pizza under the hat.
And someone said,
"That's not enough
pizza for a week."
It is if you intermittent fast.
[ Laughter ]
If you don't know,
intermittent fasting
is a diet that also
doesn't work.
[ Laughter ]
We've been talking about
the supermarket chain Aldi.
And, uh...
It just occurred to me today,
right?
I'm working on this --
my "Corrections" afternoon,
and...it occurred to me
how funny it would be
if Snoop Dogg had, like,
a partnership with Aldi,
and, you know,
through Snoop Dogg,
they would offer all these
pretzels, all these chips
and Aldi's nuts.
[all deez nuts]
[ Laughter ]
Pretty proud of it.
Shoemaker and I share a wall.
If you're wondering,
that's why, at 10:00 a.m.,
you heard me scream, "Eureka!"
[ Laughter ]
But, guys, I do this sometimes.
I come up with a thing,
and I worry
I might not be the first guy
who came up with "Aldi's nuts."
And, sure enough, I, uh --
I took a look,
and, oof, the youth
of today have me beat.
It was not --
Not by a long shot
did I get to
"Aldi's nuts" first.
So, uh, that is a joke
that left the station years ago.
And because of that,
it's not like
I was gonna waste Tara's time
and have her make a graphic.
That would have looked
probably something like that.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Mm-hmm ♪
Oh, if Donald Trump
had fallen into a lake,
we talked about you would not
be able to get him out
with a pool scoop.
You would need a winch.
Shout-out to all the jackals
who wrote that if they couldn't
find a winch, that a panicked
Donald Trump would
probably insist
they go looking for one
and would scream, "Winch hunt."
[ Laughter ]
There are no lawns in Japan.
I don't know what joke
I made that implied there were.
But a lot of you told me
there aren't.
Apologies.
[ Laughter ]
The French Revolution happened
in the 18th century,
not to the 19th century.
A lot of you were really mad
about us getting that wrong.
But, guys, there were --
you could still
feel the repercussions
in the 19th century.
Okay?
You don't have a revolution
and then just move on.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause it's awkward for a --
You have to then live together.
You know?
You'll see people --
les poissons --
that you...
[ Laughter ]
You know, that you were on --
And you're like,
"Oh, you look familiar.
Did I perhaps see you
through a wall
of stacked-up furniture?"
They stacked up a lot --
the most --
They said,
of all armed conflicts,
French Revolution had the most
walls of stacked-up furniture.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, we've been
talking about Frankenstein.
And based on some of
the plot details I discussed
last week, many of you jumped
to the conclusions
that I have never read the book
by Mary Shelley
and I've only seen
the 1931 horror movie.
That is not true.
I did read the book.
But I went back, and I dug up
my copy of the book,
and I realized --
I realized what happened.
I read this version.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of, someone wrote
about "Frankenstein,"
"The villagers
ostracized and persecuted
a sensitive soul purely because
he was different,
and their behavior
cannot be excused.
Sort of like
what Seth does with Wally."
[ Laughter ]
I would say Frankenstein does
remind me of Wally in that,
once we started
putting Wally on camera,
we created a monster.
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes there's a comment
so succinctly written
that I just want
to share it with you.
Somebody wrote, "Seth clearly
knows nothing about the Moon."
You got me.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know a [bleep] thing
about the Moon.
And here's why.
Everything you learn about it
ruins the magic.
[ Laughter ]
Talk to a Moon scientists
and they'll ruin everything.
"There's no man in it.
It's not made of cheese."
[ Laughter ]
"It's round."
Okay.
Then how come I can draw it
on a piece of paper?
[ Laughter ]
Are there --
I just --
I want to be the first --
I want to be --
[ Laughter ]
You never hear of flat-mooners.
I'm gonna be a flat-mooner.
Yeah, I did my own research.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, are flat-earthers,
flat-mooners, too?
It would be so weird
if they were, like, full on --
they were good with
the Moon being round.
I don't know.
"The Earth is flat."
"What about the moon?"
"I'm not [bleep] crazy."
[ Laughter ]
"Come on, dude."
I did get waxing and waning
exactly backwards.
Waxing means getting bigger,
waning means getting smaller.
Wax on, wane off.
That was the right way.
Do you want to do Miyagi?
Might be --
[ Laughter ]
Might be a fun way for everybody
to see on camera
the first time.
[ Laughter ]
Shoemaker...
You're in the costume.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
I wrote a joke about
Superman going into a bank
and then coming out with his
underpants pulled over his head
by the bank robbers.
In my mind,
if you pulled
underpants over someone's head,
they would come down --
You know, like,
you'd pull it down.
This is what graphics
came up with.
Just a [bleep] kickass hat.
[ Laughter ]
Just, like, a kryptonite-proof
bike helmet.
[ Laughter ]
So, again, shame on me.
Roll down to graphics.
And I'm like,
"Is that what you think
Superman's underpants
look like?"
And of course, they're all like,
"What do you think
they look like?"
[ Laughter ]
Weirdos.
All right.
I want to come clean about --
Well, first of all, you know,
obviously, we're aware
of the jackal mug.
Very popular in the merch.
Someone sent me this.
They just made this.
Don't. Make. Better. Mugs.
Than. Us.
[ Laughter ]
But here's the thing.
You know, I said we were
gonna do a sweepstakes
because I felt bad for
our foreign viewers,
foreign jackals,
who can't order, um...
Can't order the mugs online
because NBC doesn't
ship to other countries
because, um...
they just don't want
to monetize it.
[ Laughter ]
I say, "Don't you want
to monetize it?"
And they say, "It's art."
[ Laughter ]
So, anyway, I said, "Hey.
Everybody from overseas,
send in a postcard,
and then I'll draw one out."
Sweepstakes, right?
And we'll send -- one lucky
foreign jackal
is gonna get a mug.
And so anyway,
I didn't check with anyone
when I did this.
I don't run "Corrections"
by anybody.
And for the last month
since I've done that,
I've been having tons
of meetings with NBC's
legal department, hours a day.
And then, yesterday,
they said, "Here's the deal.
Anyone who sent in a postcard
you have to send a mug to."
And I said,
"How did this take a month?"
And they said,
"We wanted to bill you a bunch."
[ Laughter ]
-So, anyways, now...
By the way,
window's closed, pals.
[ Laughter ]
Postmark yesterday.
So, long story short,
if you're
an international viewer,
and we can
read your handwriting --
We saved them all --
and you are gonna get a mug.
Okay? Congratulations.
You broke the code or whatever.
[ Laughter ]
Just know, to fill
an order this large,
while you're laughing it up,
everyone at the mug factory
has to work on Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
Not that you jackals would care.
But you know what?
I also want to stress something.
It was my mistake.
Mea culpa.
I should've checked.
Not gonna make NBC pay for this.
I will pay for the mugs out of
my own pocket.
I'm gonna do that.
Shoemaker, hold me to it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
But you know what?
So I'm gonna pay for the mugs.
I'm also gonna use...
However much I pay for the mugs,
I'm gonna use --
whatever it costs,
I'm gonna take that
same amount of money,
and I'm gonna get
something fun for me.
You know what I mean?
[ Cellphone rings ]
Because I think I also
deserve something fun.
Hey, honey.
Yeah.
Just "Corrections" and then...
Nope.
I can't get something fun?
[ Laughter ]
No, no, I know, but...
Well, what would you
spend it on?
Yeah, but...
Them going to college
isn't fun for me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
Well...
Congratulations to all
you jackals out there.
We are gonna send them via
the cheapest possible
shipping option.
And have a very happy
Thanksgiving, everybody.
I will --
You will see me in two weeks.